Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在深入今天的节目之前，我想快速通知大家一个目前正在进行的激动人心的好消息。如果你曾经想过如何创造源源不断的被动收入，而不是把时间无休止地出卖给金钱，那么你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）主讲的“冲刺经常性收入”挑战赛（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战赛旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是有抱负的心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是从事完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. Without a merry entrance Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
这些原则都对你适用。本次活动还有机会赢取由丽莎本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的专属链接参加挑战，你还将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特ント博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）一对一辅导一小时的机会。你想了解更多吗？你当然想。前往我的 Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），或者查看我的社交媒体渠道，或者给我发个简短的私信，我会把所有详情发给你。好了，让我们继续今天的节目。如果你想成为一名心理学家，就让这期节目作为你的指南吧。没有欢快的开场白。嗨，欢迎收看《有抱负的心理学家播客》。
I am joined today by the lovely Meg Sota. Hi Meg. Hi, it's lovely to be here. Really nice to have you here. And we connected on LinkedIn. I'm not lying, I do like LinkedIn, I mention it quite a lot but I'm often on there and yeah we were just thinking about a number of issues and I was like why didn't, how do you feel maybe about coming along and
我今天邀请到了可爱的梅格·索塔（Meg Sota）。嗨，梅格。嗨，很高兴来到这里。非常高兴你能来。我们是通过领英（LinkedIn）认识的。说实话，我真的很喜欢领英，我经常提到它，我经常刷领英，是的，我们当时在探讨一些问题，然后我就想，要不要考虑来
recording a podcast episode and you were naturally a little bit apprehensive but we, you went for it and so thank you for being brave. So, yeah, we were talking about a number of things. But before we do that, could you just give us a little bit of an overview about who you are and what stage of your journey you're at as an aspiring psychologist, Meg? Yeah, of course. So currently I'm a trainee PWP. I started that role in March and before that I worked in more um private mental health organizations it more admin than a clinical um I've spent a couple of placements doing kind of voluntary assistant psychology post but never had
录制一期播客节目呢？你一开始自然有点犹豫和担忧，但你还是勇敢地接受了，所以谢谢你的勇敢。所以，是的，我们讨论了很多事情。但在我们开始之前，梅格，你能否简单介绍一下你是谁，以及作为一名有抱负的心理学家，你目前处于你职业旅程的哪个阶段？好的，没问题。目前我是一名心理福祉从业人员（PWP）培训生。我在三月份开始了这个角色。在此之前，我在更多的私人心理健康机构工作，行政工作多于临床工作。我做过几次志愿助理心理学家的实习，但从来没有
um an employed I've kind of preferred to go down the PWP route as it seemed kind of voluntary assistant psychology post but never had an employed I've kind of preferred to go down the PWP route as it seemed kind of right for me at the time and I think I've wanted to be a clinical psychologist since I knew what they were and I've taken a bit of a break and here and there I think after my undergrad I was like no more psychology I need a break and so I went kind of more into organizational psychology for a year and but clinical psychology brought me back and that's my interest and so I'm just kind of building up my experience hopefully get my qualification to my PWP and then we'll see where it goes. Brilliant so not everyone listening to this will know what a PWP is could you tell us a little bit a quick run through about what they are what they do and how the training for it works please
做过正式雇员。我其实更倾向于走 PWP 这条路线，因为它当时对我来说似乎很合适。我想我从知道临床心理学家是什么开始，就一直想成为一名临床心理学家。我中间断断续续休息了一段时间，本科毕业后我想着再也不学心理学了，我需要休息一下，于是我转向了组织心理学领域一年，但临床心理学又把我吸引了回来，这才是我的兴趣所在。所以现在我只是在积累经验，希望通过 PWP 获得资格认证，然后再看未来的发展方向。太棒了。并不是所有收听节目的听众都知道什么是 PWP，梅格，你能否简单向我们介绍一下什么是 PWP、他们的工作内容以及相关的培训是如何运作的吗？
Meg? Yeah so it's abbreviated for psychological well-being practitioner and basically the role is within the stepped care model of mental health and it's a step two approach so basically the role looks like you are you are a therapist but in a step two approach which means that it's very low intensity kind of working with people with mild to moderate anxiety and depression and what we do is it's a lot more like guided self-help than actually you know treating a client so they will come to us if they have these issues we assess them see if we can meet their needs and then when we go into treatment I suppose every fortnight or weekly sessions we will go through various different interventions with them depending on what they're struggling with and so the training for that is 12 months
好的，PWP 是心理福祉从业人员（Psychological Wellbeing Practitioner）的缩写。基本上，这个角色属于心理健康分级照护模型（stepped care model）的一部分，属于第二级（step two）方法。所以基本上这个角色的工作就像是一名治疗师，但采用的是第二级的方法，这意味着它是低强度的，主要与轻度到中度焦虑和抑郁的人群合作。我们所做的事情与其说是治疗客户，不如说是进行大量的指导性自助。如果客户有这些问题，他们会来找我们，我们对他们进行评估，看看我们是否能满足他们的需求。然后当我们进入治疗阶段时，大概每两周或每周进行一次会话，我们会根据他们的困扰与他们一起经历各种不同的干预措施。因此，该培训为期 12 个月，
and you're at uni maybe one or two days a week and the rest of the time you spend in service and then once you've finished your training that's when you are fully qualified and a lot of people step up and after they've finished their training or after they've spent a year or two are qualified so then step three is like your high intensity CBT therapists and or similarly people will then try to get on to the doctor as well so it's a really good way because it's very very clinical and you have a lot of contacts in a week a lot of clinical hours it's very high volume work and you don't you know have a long-term relation like therapeutic relationship with your clients but you get through a lot of them and so it's a really really good experience to build up your clinical skills but potentially a bit draining as well if it's if it's absolutely yeah absolutely draining
你可能每周有一到两天在大学上课，其余时间在服务机构工作。培训结束后，你就正式具备了完全的资质。许多人在完成培训后或者在工作了一两年后会选择晋升。第三级（step three）则对应高强度的 CBT（认知行为治疗）治疗师，或者同样地，人们也会尝试考入博士项目。这是一个非常好的途径，因为它的临床属性非常强，你每周有大量的接触机会和大量的临床工时，工作量非常大。虽然你不会与客户建立长期的治疗关系，但你能接触到非常多的客户。因此，这对于积累临床技能来说是非常非常好的经验，但如果工作量实在太大，可能也会有点消耗精力。绝对是的，绝对非常消耗精力。
I think that I think you need to kind of manage your expectations of the of the role and of the service and because step two care is the first kind of point of call after your GP so you know we get through a lot of assessments and a lot of them won't be suitable for the service you know they'll need either higher intensity treatment or even outside services you know if it's more specific within trauma or anything that basically can't be contained within you know six half an hour sessions so it can be very draining but for the people that it's meant for it works for and so I think that just needs to be kind of like bared in mind if people are looking at the looking at going
我认为你需要调整自己对这个角色以及对服务机构的期望。因为第二级照护是全科医生（GP）之后的第一个求助点，所以我们要完成大量的评估。其中许多评估对象并不适合这项服务，他们需要更高强度的治疗，甚至是外部机构的治疗，比如如果涉及更具体的创伤问题，或者任何基本上无法在六次半小时的会话中解决的问题。所以它可能会非常消耗精力，但对于需要它的人来说，它确实有效。因此，如果人们正考虑从事 PWP 工作，这一点是需要牢记在心的。
into a PWP wrong. Brilliant and I know one of the common questions I'll be asked is well do you get paid to train do you have to pay to do the course could you talk us through the finances a little bit Meg? Yep so you don't have to pay to go on the course that is all paid for and you your starting salary is a band four in the NHS and I think it goes up to band five once you are qualified but yeah you have no payments to for university fees or anything like that it's all covered within the service brilliant so it's sort of comparable to an assistant post yeah absolutely yeah but you're getting specific training specific sort of modalities and for a specific client group is it all adult work nope so you can you kind of choose because you have your adult IAPT services. So PWPs work under the IAPT, which is Improving Access to Psychological Therapy service. But then there's also a child and young persons PWP late teens some are seen as children some are seen as adults
太棒了。我知道人们经常问我的一个问题是：培训有薪水吗？我需要自费上课吗？梅格，你能跟我们聊聊资金方面的情况吗？好的，你不需要自费去上这门课，所有的费用都是涵盖的。你在 NHS（英国国家医疗服务体系）的起始薪级是 Band 4，获得资格后好像会上升到 Band 5。是的，你不需要支付大学学费或任何此类费用，所有这些都由服务机构承担。太棒了！所以这有点类似于助理职（assistant post）？是的，完全是。但你接受的是针对特定客户群体的特定培训和特定模式。这都是针对成人的工作吗？不，你可以选择，因为你有成人 IAPT 服务。PWPs 在 IAPT（改善心理治疗途径服务）下工作。除此之外，还有针对儿童和青少年的 PWP，晚期青少年有时被视为儿童，有时被视为成人，
and so for instance you know you could have a 17 year old client if you're in an adult IAP service and there'll be certain safeguarding procedures and things that you will have to kind of do that you might not have to do for you know your 40 year old client or something so there is a little bit of a crossover but there are two different roles great thank you for that and one of the reasons we were chatting on socials is thinking about when life deviates from the course we'd intended and the ensuing panic that can you know be awakened within us when that happens of you know but I want to get on to training by a certain year or a certain age and you know what will this say about me and how will it look on my CV and you know and I was like
举个例子，如果你在成人 IAPT 服务机构工作，你可能会接待一个 17 岁的客户，这时就会有一些保障程序和事情是你必须去做的，而这些可能并不需要针对你的 40 岁客户去做。所以两者之间确实有一些交集，但它们是两个不同的角色。太好了，谢谢你的解答。我们在社交媒体上聊天的一个原因，是想到了当生活偏离我们原定的轨道时，那种随之而来的恐慌——当事情发生时，我们内心会被唤醒（比如：我想要在某一年或某一岁之前进入培训，这会说明什么？它在我的简历上看起来会怎样？），当时我就想……
hold on it's okay you know there's no race yes and we you know we get there when it's right for us. And I firmly believe I got on training when it was the right time for me. And had I got on the year before, even though I applied, I would have been a bit out of my depth. I just wasn't ready at that stage. And, you know, there's that sense of what's for you doesn't pass you by and that you know I know there's a great deal of um competition for these places on doctoral training but um you absolutely wouldn't want to be looking around the room and thinking everybody else is amazing and I really not just as an imposter syndrome I really genuinely do not know what I'm doing. Like, I feel like this is wildly outside my comfort zones. You know, what I want for you and what I want for everyone else who is successful at getting a place is that they look around and they see their contemporaries, actually. You know, so we would expect on training that at some points, especially if you've worked in a particular client area before that you're like oh this is a bit boring
等一下，没关系的，没有所谓的竞赛。是的，我们在适合自己的时候自然会到达目的地。我坚信，我进入培训项目的时候正是我最合适的时候。如果我早一年进去，尽管我当时申请了，我也可能会有些力不从心。我当时还没准备好。而且，那种“属于你的东西是不会从你身边溜走的”的感觉……我知道博士培训的名额竞争非常激烈，但你绝对不想环顾四周，心想“这里其他所有人都太棒了，而我真的……”，这不仅仅是冒名顶替综合症，而是我真的不知道自己在做什么。就好像我觉得这完全超出了我的舒适区。我希望你以及所有成功获得名额的人能够环顾四周，看到的是与自己旗鼓相当的同龄人。所以，我们预计在培训的某些时候，特别是如果你以前在某个特定的客户领域工作过，你可能会觉得“这有点无聊，
I sort of feel like I know this but as training progresses you might find that teaching on learning disabilities intellectual disabilities or you know different areas of mental health that you haven't worked with before you will feel less skilled and so that you've got more to learn but there should be some feelings of mastery and what we're doing which shouldn't feel like totally starting afresh but there should be some bits where you're like this is a bit trickier than I imagined um you know it should feel like a bit of a stretch but not wildly um you know wildly out of your comfort zone so we were speaking about um the impact of work but generally our mental health and how that can how that can affect us at times you know
我觉得我懂这些”。但随着培训的深入，你可能会发现关于学习障碍、智力障碍或者其他你以前没有接触过的心理健康领域的教学，会让你觉得自己技能有所欠缺，需要学习的东西还有很多。尽管如此，我们所做的事情中仍然应该有一些掌握感，不应该感觉完全是从头开始；但也会有一些部分让你觉得“这比我想象的要棘手一点”，它应该带给你一点挑战，但又不能完全超出你的舒适区。所以我们之前谈到了工作对我们的影响，更广泛地说是我们的心理健康，以及它有时如何影响我们。你知道的，
I've absolutely had time off for my mental health in the past so when my dad died I took a chunk of time off to kind of grieve I was qualified at that point but absolutely if that had happened during my training I would have done that during my training um and but I'm reflecting on well if that had happened when I was an assistant psychologist would I have still felt that pressure then to keep on striving and to keep my nose to the grindstone I wonder if I would have done more so and so I think there's something around the compassionate voices within the services we work in and I guess the compassionate voices within this podcast as well that really encourage you to see yourself as unique and special and important and that we treat you as such in a service and we you know I know when we are an
我过去绝对因为心理健康问题请过假。当我父亲去世时，我请了一大段时间来悲伤。当时我已经具备了资格，但如果这件事发生我的培训期间，我绝对也会在培训期间这样做。我在反思，如果这发生在我作为助理心理学家的时候，我当时还会感受到那种不断奋斗、埋头苦干的压力吗？我想我可能会承受更多。所以，我认为这涉及到我们工作的服务机构中那些充满同情的声音，以及我猜也包括本播客中充满同情的声音，它们真正鼓励你将自己视为独一无二、特别且重要的人，并且我们在服务中也是这样对待你的。我知道当我们在
aspiring psychologist it can feel like you're just a number in the system sometimes um don't know if anyone listening to this has listened to episode 52 of the podcast but it is um all about how to get an assistant psychologist post in modern times and we're thinking about contextual admissions um and that is with with Dr Alistair and with Anna as well and it's a really useful episode and definitely I feel that their service is getting it right in terms of treating people as unique and important and special and that they're not thinking about them as short-term fly-by-night employees they really want to welcome them back as qualified staff. They want them to feel so understood, validated, seen, heard and important that they want to come back. You know, it's not like you clock off on your last day as an aspiring psychologist and you think, thank God for that.
作为有抱负的心理学家时，有时会感觉自己只是系统中的一个数字。不知道收听这个节目的听众有没有听过播客的第 52 期，那一期是关于如何在现代获得助理心理学家职位的，我们探讨了上下文招生（contextual admissions），嘉宾是阿利斯泰尔博士（Dr Alistair）和安娜（Anna）。那是一期非常有用的节目，我绝对觉得他们的服务在对待人员方面做得很好——把他们当作独一无二、重要且特别的人来对待，而不是把他们当作短期、随性的雇员，他们真的希望以合格员工的身份欢迎他们回来。他们希望让他们感到如此被理解、被认可、被看到、被倾听和受到重视，以至于他们想要回来。这不像你在作为有抱负的心理学家的最后一天打卡下班，然后心里想：“谢天谢地，终于结束了。”
You know, this would be the ultimate level of success. It's like when we're raising children that if your children choose to be in your life in adult life that's the biggest you know the biggest um well done isn't it you know a sense that we've allowed them to individuate but they're still choosing to be in our life and i think the same is true of the services we work in if we are super keen to go back to them and still be in their lives when we are qualified that is that is good you know because it says that we've had a decent decent treatment and care so um please don't share more than you want to but would you be able to talk us through
你知道的，这会是成功的最高境界。这就好比我们在抚养孩子，如果你的孩子在成年后选择留在你的生活中，那就是最大的成就，对吧？那种感觉是我们允许他们实现个体化（individuate），但他们仍然选择留在我们的生活中。我认为我们工作的服务机构也是如此：如果我们非常热切地想要回到他们身边，在我们获得资格后仍然留在他们的生活中，那这就是一件好事，因为这说明我们得到了体面的对待和照顾。所以，请不要分享任何超出你舒适范围的事情，但你能跟我们聊聊你是如何
how you recognize actually you weren't really well enough for work um whilst you were um whilst you're undergoing your training but again keep yourself safe and don't share more than you want to. Yeah absolutely so I think I've I'm sure people can relate especially in this field that you always try to kind of shove your own feelings down and you want to get on with the job and you want to be perfect and you want to do your best and you want to give everything for your clients and it was earlier on in the year and I was thinking I'm not feeling so good um and I'm trying to deliver um you know meet service outcomes or try and impress my employers and my uni tutors and things like that and I just had no energy left in the tank um so I couldn't possibly
在培训期间意识到自己其实并没有准备好工作的？再次强调，请保护好自己，不要分享超过你意愿的内容。好的，没问题。我想大家，特别是在这个领域的人，都能感同身受：你总是试图压抑自己的真实感受，只想把工作做好，想表现得完美，想尽全力，想为客户付出一切。那是今年早些时候，当时我觉得自己状态不太好，我试图产出成果、迎合服务目标，或者试图给雇主和大学导师留下深刻印象等等，而我体内的能量已经彻底耗尽了，所以我根本不可能
give any more than than I did and it was at that point where I thought okay this isn't working right now I need to take some time to regroup you know do the do some inner work before I then feel able to kind of give my services to other people, because I'm a strong believer of, you know, if we don't look after ourselves, we can't look after anybody else. And so although there was a lot of inner conflict with that, because I'm, you know, very much a perfectionist, and I really want to just give my all all the time. The reality of it was my personal situation had changed and I had to kind of respond to that in the most effective way without, you know, kind of sabotaging future Meg
付出比当时更多的努力了。正是在那个时候，我觉得“好吧，这样行不通，我需要花点时间重新调整，做一些内在的心理工作，然后才觉得有能力把我的服务奉献给其他人”。因为我坚信，如果我们不照顾好自己，我们就无法照顾好任何人。因此，尽管这其中伴随着很多内心冲突，因为我本质上是个完美主义者，非常渴望随时随地付出全部。但现实情况是，我的个人状况发生了变化，我必须以最有效的方式对此做出回应，而不能破坏未来的梅格，
or also current Meg. So there was definitely a fine balance of trying to, you know, assess the situation, see what I could give and what I couldn't. And it turned out I just couldn't give what what my clients needed. And I think for me, that was the main thing that went through my head was, you know, we have our clients that come into the service for support and for guidance. And at that moment in time, I didn't feel like I could give them my best authentic self and so I spoke with my airline manager and his manager who have been very very supportive and they just said no you need to look after you first take some time
同时也不能破坏现在的梅格。所以这绝对是一种微妙的平衡，试图评估形势，看看我能付出什么，不能付出什么。结果证明，我实在无法给予客户们所需要的东西。我认为对我来说，脑海中最主要的一个想法是：我们的客户来到服务机构是为了寻求支持和指导，而在那个特定的时刻，我觉得自己无法向他们展现出我最真实、最好的自我。因此，我与我的直线经理和他的经理进行了沟通，他们非常非常支持我。他们说：“不，你得先把照顾好你自己放在首位，花点时间休息一下，
we'll come back when you're ready and I think for me you know the timeline of wanting to be qualified as a PWP by a certain time apply for the doctorate by a certain time all of that was going through my head when I did you say okay I'll take a break and there was so much shame that brought up that got brought up because you know you you want to do what you intended to do and life unfortunately doesn't work like that you can have the next decade of your life planned out fully and something is gonna turn show up and turn your path a different direction so it's definitely been a learning curve this year but I think I kind of want to explain that it's probably for the best what's happened this year because I think I kind of want to explain that it's probably for the best what's
等你准备好了再回来。”对我来说，我想在某个特定时间点获得 PWP 资格、在某个特定时间点申请博士学位的这种时间规划，当我决定说“好吧，我要休息一下”时，所有这些想法都在我脑海中翻江倒海，由此带来了巨大的羞耻感。因为你总是想按照原定计划去做，但不幸的是，生活并不总是那样运转的。你可以把未来十年的生活规划得满满当当，但总会有意想不到的事情出现，把你的道路引向完全不同的方向。所以今年绝对是一个学习曲线，但我认为我想解释的是，今年发生的事情可能反而是最好的安排，因为这能让我成为一名更好的从业人员。因为我有时间留给自己，设法完成了自我调适。我想很多人都会感同身受，他们都有自己的个人问题。我的意思是，我认为我们喜欢这个领域的主要原因，正是因为我们感同身受，
happened this year because I think it could make me into a better practitioner you know because I've had the time for myself I've managed to work on myself and I think a lot of people will be able to relate that they have their own stuff I mean I think that's the main reason why we like to be in the field is because we know we know what the main reason why we like to be in the field is because we know what it's like and we want to be able to help people who have been in similar situations or feeling in similar ways.
我们知道这种经历是什么样的，我们希望能够帮助那些处于类似境况或有着相似感受的人。
So by me really focusing on my inner work and healing and, you know, all that sort of stuff, I think, you know, when March comes and when the trainee PWP course starts again, I think I'm in a much better position to be able to take it. And although I felt, you know, I loved the job that I was doing and I enjoyed going to uni and I thought every, you know, I soaked up all of the content and it was honestly, it was, I found it great fun. I knew that it wasn't long lasting. It was, you know, burnout was pending and burnout happened. And so, but now, you know, after experiencing that, I'm now able to implement, you know, my own well start my training to know okay what are the signs of that
所以通过真正专注于我的内在工作和疗愈，你知道的，诸如此类的事情，我想，当3月到来、见习心理 wellbeing 顾问（PWP）课程再次开始时，我认为我将处于一个好得多的位置来应对它。尽管我觉得，你知道的，我热爱我正在做的工作，我也喜欢去大学上课，而且我觉得每，你知道的，我吸收了所有的内容，老实说，我觉得这非常有趣。我知道它不会长久。你知道的，职业倦怠即将来临，而倦怠也确实发生了。所以，但现在，你知道的，在经历了这些之后，我能够开始实施，你知道的，我自己的，开始我的培训，去了解，好吧，这些迹象是什么
you're working too hard or what are the signs that you need to take a break or things like that so I think it's really important to try not to try and go by your timeline which I'm still battling with you know um but at the end of the day where if you do have to take time off I think it can only be a positive because you are always learning you are thank you for sharing that with us and um well done for having that level of insight and reflection as well so it sounds like that had been you know self-directed that you discuss that with your team but I know um from working in services myself in the past that sometimes it's a top-down process sometimes people recognize with you I'm not sure this is you know the best time for you to be here
你工作太努力了，或者你需要休息的迹象是什么，诸如此类。所以我认为非常重要的一点是，尽量不要按照别人的时间表来，这也是我仍在抗争的，你知道的，嗯……但归根结底，如果你真的必须请假，我认为这只能是一件积极的事情，因为你总是在学习，你是在——谢谢你与我们分享这些，嗯，为你有这种程度的洞察力和反思能力点赞。所以听起来这似乎是，你知道的，自我导向的，你和你的团队讨论过这件事，但我知道，从我过去在服务机构工作的经历来看，有时这是一个自上而下的过程，有时人们会和你一起意识到，我不确定这是否是，你知道的，你在这里的最佳时机
right now and they might highlight things that they've observed and that can feel really triggering and add to shame but hopefully people are having conversations with their superiors or their supervisors that feel compassionate and don't feel judgy or critical or hostile. You know we want our staff teams to be well and thriving so that they can help our clients to do the same. Yeah I'm really pleased that you had a good experience from your um supervisors if you could take some of the learning you've got this year um to apply retrospectively is there anything you think could have been different that would have led to a different outcome at the time yes lots of things I think hindsight is is something of a mystery. But yes, so I think where I'm
现在，他们可能会指出他们观察到的事情，这可能会让人觉得极具触发性并增加羞耻感，但希望人们能与他们的上级或主管进行充满同情心、不带有评判性、批判性或敌意的对话。你知道的，我们希望我们的员工团队保持健康和蓬勃发展，以便他们能够帮助我们的客户也做到这一点。是的，我真的很高兴你从你的主管那里有了好的体验，如果你能把今年学到的一些东西拿来回顾性地应用，你觉得有什么事情本可以做得不同，从而在当时导向一个不同的结果吗？是的，有很多事情，我想事后诸葛亮确实是一件挺奇妙的事。但是，是的，所以我想我在
based and where the job was, complete other side of the country. And when I think when you're in the position of being offered this, you know, fancy new job on your road to being a clinical psychologist, you kind of take it without thinking about it because there's the places are so competitive and somebody says that they want you and you're there and so I just took it and I was like okay I didn't really think I didn't really think it through at all you know I'm from the north of the country and on a purely logistic level the north is cheaper than the south and so then transferring to the south I was like I don't actually know if this is feasible um but so at the time I would commute I had a family friend in the same city so I would commute down stay with them and commute back up and it was four and a half hours to five hours at a time
所在地和工作所在的地点，完全在国家的另一端。而我想当你处于被提供这份工作的位置时，你知道的，在成为临床心理学家的道路上，这份光鲜亮丽的新工作，你某种程度上会毫不犹豫地接受它，因为名额太有竞争性了，有人说他们想要你，而你就在那儿，所以我当时就接受了，我想，好吧，我真的没有想过，我根本没有仔细考虑过，你知道的，我来自北方，纯粹从后勤角度来看，北方比南方便宜，所以转到南方时，我想，我其实不知道这是否可行，嗯……但当时我会通勤，我在同一个城市有一个家庭朋友，所以我就会通勤下去，和他们待在一起，然后再通勤回来，单程要四个半小时到五个小时
um so that was kind of the first thing that I was like hmm maybe I did not think this through um and also I think the biggest thing for me is how much you put into the role I think it's so you know it means so much to us you know to do a good job and to do great but I don't think anything is worth the expense of your wellbeing. And I think, you know, I would do overtime. I would, when I was finishing work, I would read through all of the uni reading, even the recommended that wasn't, you know, core content. And even on weekends and before I went to bed
所以那基本上是第一件让我觉得，嗯，也许我根本没想清楚的事……而且我也觉得，对我来说最重要的一点是你在角色中投入了多少。我觉得这太，你知道的，这对我们意义重大，你知道的，要做好工作，要表现出色，但我认为没有任何东西值得以牺牲你的福祉为代价。而且我想，你知道的，我会加班。当我完成工作时，我会通读大学所有的阅读材料，甚至是那些不是，你知道的，核心内容的推荐材料。甚至在周末和睡觉前
and my whole life revolved around being a PWP. And I think that that's not possible nobody can work 24 hours a day and although I wasn't you know seeing clients all that time it was constantly on my mind and so I think I would have tried to set more boundaries in place you know when I log off from work you know because I worked from home as well as in service, I'd log off. I should have hid my laptop or make it a complete anti-work zone so I can then do things for me and my family, my friends,
我整个生活都围绕着成为一名 PWP 转。我觉得这根本不可能，没有人可以一天工作24小时，尽管我不是在所有那些时间里都见客户，但它一直占据着我的脑海，所以我想我本可以尝试设定更多的界限，你知道的，当我从工作下班时，你知道的，因为我在家工作，也在服务机构工作，我会下班。我本应该把我的笔记本电脑藏起来，或者把它变成一个完全的反工作区，这样我就可以为我自己、我的家人、我的朋友做一些事情
and then come back fresh the next day instead of feeling like you're just continually just being a PWP. And I think the journey of becoming a psychologist or a practitioner in any discipline, really, I think you need to be able to take the time because you just want to soak up everything because you do feel like you're on a timeline and you feel like you need to get through it as quick as possible.
然后第二天精神焕发地回来，而不是觉得自己一直在不停地当一个 PWP。而且我认为成为一名心理学家或任何学科的从业者的旅程，真的，我认为你需要能够花时间，因为你只是想吸收一切，因为你确实觉得自己背负着时间表，觉得你需要尽快完成它。
But actually, in retrospect, if I'd slowed down then that could have you know been more beneficial and I think even before taking the role I felt the pressure to do something new the role came up quite um spontaneously I was just browsing LinkedIn and it came up and I thought oh okay and then I applied and you know a week later I'd got the job and so it well there was not much time to think about anything and because you know we do want to progress on the psychology ladder we we do take things without maybe thinking it through completely and although I felt that I was you know competent enough to do the role at the time and I didn't feel out of my depth any more than I should have um I think it's all about balance I think and I you know a lot of people talk about balance um you know it's coming up a lot in mindfulness
但实际上，事后看来，如果我当时慢下来，那可能会，你知道的，更有益，而且我认为甚至在接受这个职位之前，我就感到了要做新事情的压力，这个职位出现得相当，嗯，很突然，我只是在浏览领英，它就出现了，我想，哦，好吧，然后我申请了，你知道的，一个星期后我就得到了这份工作，所以，嗯，没有太多时间去思考任何事情，而且因为，你知道的，我们确实想在心理学阶梯上前进，我们确实会接受事情，而可能没有完全想清楚，尽管我觉得当时我完全有能力胜任这个角色，而且我并没有感到超出我的能力范围，比我应该感受到的更多，嗯，我觉得这全关乎平衡，我觉得，你和我，你知道的，很多人都在谈论平衡
practice and all that sort of thing but it's so important and I always take it for granted and so I don't need mindfulness you know I just need to keep working but actually if you can just slow down and take it a step at a time and don't put too much pressure on yourself to be perfect then I think that would have got me a lot further. Thank you for sharing that and yeah four and a half hour commute is never going to be doing anyone a good service that's going to make you exhausted before you've even begun that's going to slap the soul out of anybody and i'm guessing if there'd been a choice for um a course closer to you you'd have gone for that but this isn't what that was it was like one you know one employing trust who were employing trainee to pwps you saw it applied and that was that um but yeah with with a compassionate choice
你知道的，这在正念练习和诸如此类的事情中经常出现，但它太重要了，我总是把它视为理所当然，所以我觉得我不需要正念，你知道的，我只需要继续工作，但实际上，如果你能放慢脚步，一步一个脚印，不要给自己施加太多的完美主义压力，那么我认为这会让我走得更远。谢谢你分享这些，是的，四个半小时的通勤永远不会对任何人有任何好处，那会让你在还没开始之前就精疲力竭，那会把任何人的灵魂都抽空，我猜如果当时有选择，比如离你更近的课程，你肯定会选择那个，但事实并非如此，就像一个，你知道的，一个雇主信托基金在招收见习 PWP，你看到了，申请了，就是这样，但是，嗯，带着同情心的选择
you likely would have gone for one that was half an hour down the road from you but that wasn't available and just to you know put some context in this i absolutely did this i had a bit i had a bit of a wild phase where i like decided I needed an NHS assistant post and I needed it to be in a different clinical area than the one I was working in and I scattergunned the country with applications and when it came to it and I was offered an interview in Birmingham and an interview in Nottingham and an interview in the Lake District and I was living in rural Northamptonshire it came to it I was like I don't even want to live in the lakes I think I thought oh that'd be all right be like an hour and a half or so up the motorway no that would have been like
你很可能会选择一个离你只有半小时车程的地方，但当时没有。为了，你知道的，提供一些背景，我绝对做过这种事，我曾有过一段疯狂的时期，当时我好像决定我需要一个 NHS 的助理岗位，而且我需要它在一个与我当时的工作不同的临床领域，我向全国各地海投了申请，当结果出来时，我获得了伯明翰的面试、诺丁汉的面试和湖区（Lake District）的面试，而当时我住在北安普顿郡的农村，当结果出来时，我想我甚至都不想住在湖区，我想我当时想，哦，那挺不错的，离高速公路大概一个半小时左右吧，不，那其实得有
three and a half four hours that. That's a long way. You just didn't think, Marianne. And we're allowed to be mindful and make choices that work for ourselves and our lives. And of course, you might think that would be a fantastic job, but it might have to be a fantastic job for somebody else that lives more close, you know, that lives closer than I do. And I can compassionately let that one go. I can shrink my geographical area when I'm on track or NHS jobs or wherever, so that I'm only traveling within 30 miles. And even that is probably further than I want to travel. So we can't do everything. We can't get all the experience you know I think about when I um was um an undergraduate I was 18 and I was um in uh yeah in the theoretical themes and debates
三四个小时那么远。那可太远了。你当时就是没动脑子，玛丽安。我们完全可以保持正念，做出适合我们自己和我们生活的选择。当然，你可能会认为那会是一份极其棒的工作，但它可能得由住得更近的某个人来做，你知道的，住得比我近的人，而我可以充满同情心地放手。当我浏览轨道（On Track）或 NHS 工作网或其他地方时，我可以缩小我的地理范围，这样我只在30英里以内出行。甚至这可能都比我想走得更远。所以我们无法做所有的事情。我们无法获得所有的经验，你知道的，我想起当我，嗯，还是个本科生的时候，我18岁，我在，嗯，在理论主题与辩论
lecture and the lovely Alan Granfield was teaching me and I wonder if he's maybe not around anymore because he was a little bit older at the time but but he was talking to us about the id, the ego, and the super ego, and I always remember his little impression of the id, just going me, me, me, me, more, more, more, more, more, it's all for me, it's all for me, and I feel like it was the id bit of me that was doing all of that scattergun, you know, applying and whether we just need to balance that with our ego and our super ego and our compassionate voices to just soothe everything down and give ourselves some understanding that, you know, there will be another time, there will be another job and things shouldn't feel like a massive stretch they should feel you know just
讲座中，可爱的艾伦·格兰菲尔德（Alan Granfield）在教我，我在想他现在可能已经不在了，因为他当时年纪已经有点大了，但他当时在跟我们讲本我、自我和超我，我一直记得他对本我的小模仿，就是‘我，我，我，我，更多，更多，更多，都是我的，都是我的’，我觉得我当时做那些海投、申请就是我体内的本我在作祟，你知道的，或许我们只是需要用我们的自我、超我和富有同情心的声音去平衡这一点，把一切都安抚下来，给自己一些理解，你知道的，还会有其他时间的，还会有其他工作的，事情不应该让人感觉是一次巨大的拉伸，它们应该让人感觉，你知道，就在
within our comfort zones but if they're not that's a sign so we look at window of tolerance a lot in the work I do with people if they're too much of a stretch it's going to leave you feeling you know hyper aroused or hypo ar, and those are not good states to be in. No, I'm smiling when you when you say when you share that story, because I think so many people will be in the same boat. I mean, I know a few people, I do it myself, I think, because there is this kind of expectation on the on the psychology field of, you know, the sooner you qualify, the better and, and all of that, you just you just do things, you know, you kind of it's almost like you're on autopilot, you think you're thinking at the time, but actually, you're not. And for me, especially, I had a lot going on
我们的舒适区之内，但如果不是，那这就是一个信号，所以我们在与人们合作时会大量关注容忍窗口（window of tolerance），如果它们的拉伸幅度太大，会让你感到过度唤醒（hyper aroused）或低唤醒（hypo ar），这些都不是好状态。不，当你分享这个故事时，我在微笑，因为我认为会有很多人和我有同感。我的意思是，我知道一些人，我自己也这么做，我想，因为在心理学领域存在着这样一种期待，你知道的，你越早资历达标越好，等等诸如此类，你就会直接去做，你知道的，你有点像是在自动驾驶，你以为当时自己在思考，但实际上并没有。特别是对我而言，当时我有很多事情
in my personal life at that time. And although a new job was definitely on the cards because you know I'd outgrown my my old role and I was ready to be a PWP I think within the timing of what was going on for me personally it probably wasn't a good time at all and you know with PWPs there's two intakes a year so you've got your March and your September and I could have waited till September, but I think there was that, you know, internal pressure of, no, you've got to do it now because if you take, you know, if you take, if you leave your job and just take a couple months off, then what's that going to look like on your CV?
在我的个人生活中发生。尽管新工作绝对在计划之中，因为你知道的，我已经超越了我旧的角色，我准备好成为一名 PWP，我认为就我个人当时发生的事情的时间节点来看，这可能根本不是一个好时机，而且你知道的，对于 PWP 来说，一年有两次招生，所以你有3月和9月，我本可以等到9月，但我认为存在着那种，你知道的，内部压力，不，你现在就得做，因为如果你花时间，你知道的，如果你辞职然后休息几个月，那在你的简历上会是什么样子？
And I think we all come back to this needs to look good, you know, even on your LinkedIn page, if there's any gaps in work or if there's, you know, you haven't, you've maybe done a clinical post, and then maybe reduced your hours and done more of an admin post or something like that. It, you know, it is this pressure of everything has to add up. And I think sometimes in life, the different experiences, what is what makes you a better practitioner, you know you've got more experience around you than just going from a to b to c to d you know sometimes life can take you around around the back and it could spin you around a bit but i think essentially like we just
我想我们都会回到这需要看起来不错的心态，你知道的，甚至在你的领英页面上，如果工作有任何间断，或者如果有什么，你可能做了一个临床岗位，然后可能减少了工时，做了一个更多是行政的岗位或者类似的事情。它，你知道的，就是这种一切都必须说得过去的压力。而且我认为生活中的不同经历，有时正是让你成为一个更好的从业者的原因，你知道的，你身边的经验不仅仅是从 A 到 B 到 C 到 D，你知道的，有时生活会带你走弯路，把你转得晕头转向，但我认为本质上就像我们
have to kind of like you said soothe take a breath and try and really think about what is best for us right now instead of what's best for us for five years time. Because I think that's a very big, very big inner conflict that I have. Yeah, I definitely agree. And I think this is part of the value of this podcast is because it's very different when someone who understands the profession you're in and understands the struggles that you have says hold on a minute like really like someone needed to say to me Marianne what are you doing why are you applying to the lakes like look at a map do you know where that is you know and I'd have been like oh I've been a little impulsive but a bit hasty um but there's something you know if your mum or you know your auntie goes really like it feels like they don't really understand so I think like I said this is a value of the podcast a compassionate non-judgmental
必须有点像你说的，安抚自己，深呼吸，试着真正思考现在什么对我们最好，而不是五年后什么对我们最好。因为我认为那是我内心深处一个非常巨大、非常巨大的冲突。是的，我绝对赞同。而且我认为这也是这个播客的价值所在，因为当一个理解你所在的行业、理解你所面临的挣扎的人对你说‘等一下，真的吗’时，情况就完全不同了——就像有人需要对我说，‘玛丽安，你在干什么？你为什么申请湖区？看一眼地图，你知道那在哪里吗？’你知道的，我会觉得，‘哦，我刚才有点冲动，有点草率’，但有些事，你知道的，如果是你妈妈或者你阿姨说‘真的吗’，就感觉他们其实并不真正理解，所以我想就像我说的，这就是播客的价值，一个富有同情心的、不带评判的
empathic voice just to say it's okay you know there will be time there are there are other options there is another path you can take and that's going to be okay too it's not a race even though it may feel like it so yeah learn from my past mistakes um so that you don't end up doing what I did which was you know semi on the edge of burnout as I slumped on the stairs at my parents' house sobbing because I just couldn't do it. I couldn't do it. It was all too much. You know, I can't go on a job interview to Nottingham tomorrow. I can't do it. I haven't got it in the tank because I was at that time recovering from a car crash and doing a master's in part-time whilst working full-time and whilst recovering from a breakup of a long-term
共情的声音，只是来说一句没关系的，你知道的，还会有时间，还有其他选择，还有另一条你可以走的道路，那也会没关系的，这不是一场比赛，尽管感觉起来可能像是——所以，是的，吸取我过去的教训，这样你就不会落得像我一样的下场，当时我半处在职业倦怠的边缘，瘫倒在我父母家的楼梯上嚎啕大哭，因为我实在做不下去了。我做不下去了。这一切都太多了。你知道的，我明天不能去诺丁汉参加工作面试。我做不到。我油箱里没油了，因为我当时正在从一场车祸中恢复，还要一边全职工作一边读兼职硕士，同时还在经历长期关系的破裂
relationship I didn't have the energy in the tank to get to Nottingham to go and do an interview for a job I probably didn't even really want you know and so learn from me as you listen to this and as you listen to Meg learn from that thinking about just taking stock on your individual capacity and your resources right now, which might be different than they were a few months ago, even when you applied. But you're allowed to make the decisions for you right now. And we can't, as you say, predict what might be coming and how that might affect our emotional or practical resources. And so it's always okay to take stock and continue to check
我根本没有精力去诺丁汉参加一份我可能根本不想要的工作的面试，你知道的，所以当你听这个节目以及听米格（Meg）分享时，请以我为戒，思考一下如何评估你当下的个人承受力和资源，这可能与几个月前你申请时已经不同了。但你完全可以为你当下的情况做出决定。正如你所说，我们无法预测接下来会发生什么，以及它会如何影响我们的情感或实际资源。所以随时停下来盘点一下、并继续检查
that things are working for you and actually what you've found is taking time out hasn't been as bad as you'd expected no no not at all I think you know there is that sometimes it creeps up the inner conflict and I should be in the post right now I should be doing that but by taking the time off I've you know I've learned a lot about myself I've learned a lot about kind of my approach to work to life in general and I think just spending that time of like building up some more inner awareness I think that really has kind of prompted me to move forward in a completely different way that I wouldn't have even thought of this time last year because this time last year it was go go go um but now I'm you know I'm recognizing when I'm starting to you know lose
事情是否对你有效，这永远是可以的，实际上你发现抽出时间并没有你想象的那么糟。不，不，一点也不。我想，你知道的，有时候那种内心冲突会悄然袭来，我本该已经在岗位上了，我本该在做那个，但通过请假，我，你知道的，我对自我有了很多了解，我对对待工作、对待一般生活的态度有了很多了解，而且我认为只是花时间建立更多的内在觉察，我觉得这确实促使我以一种全新的方式向前迈进，如果是在去年的这个时候，我想都不会想到，因为去年的这个时候，简直是冲冲冲，但现在我，你知道的，我开始觉察到自己什么时候开始，你知道的，失去
energy or when my tank isn't quite full or you know when personal circumstances arrive you know, when personal circumstances arrive, you know, that's life. And it's about being able to tolerate that. And like you mentioned with the window of tolerance, I think this year for me has been all about expanding my window of tolerance because this time last year, there wasn't even a window. There was maybe like a crack of tolerance. But we're getting onto a window now. So I think it's, you know know it's so important like you say to
精力，或者当我的油箱没那么满的时候，或者你知道的，当个人情况出现时，你知道的，当个人情况出现时，这就是生活。关键在于能够包容这一点。就像你提到的容忍窗口一样，我认为对我来说今年全都是关于扩大我的容忍窗口，因为去年的这个时候，甚至连个窗口都没有。可能只有一道容忍的缝隙。但我们现在正在朝着一扇窗户迈进。所以我觉得，你知道的，就像你说的，这太重要了
just to take your time with things and you know although I would much rather you know be in work I'm employed I'm just taking taking the time off and I think oh I'm so left behind my cohort is nearly qualified now that could have been me and you know all those negative thoughts and ruminations come up but I'm in such a better place than I was you know 10 months ago that actually allows me to kind of take on the role again when training restarts in March in a completely new light and I've got so much more in my tank to be able to offer and I've also got the kind of the skills now to recognize when I do need to take a break or and when I say break I mean take the weekend off or like have an evening to yourself or reduce screen time or you know anything
只要放慢节奏去处理事情，你知道的，虽然我其实更愿意去工作、去上班，但我只是在休假，然后我想着“天哪，我落后太多了，我的同届生快要拿到资格了，那本来可能是我”，你知道，所有这些负面的想法和反刍都会涌现。但我现在的状态比10个月前好太多了，这实际上让我在3月份培训重新开始时，能以一个全新的视角重新投入到这个角色中，而且我有更多的心力去付出。我现在也具备了一些技能，能够识别出我什么时候确实需要休息——当我说休息时，我是指周末不工作，或者留出一个晚上属于自己，又或者减少看屏幕的时间，或者任何类似的事情
like that which before I wouldn't have had any of it I I would, you know, be so adamant to do things my way to do it, you know, 100 percent. But, you know, you can't give 100 percent of yourself all the time. You know, you need to be able to rest. And so I think it's done me the world of good to take some time off just so I can recognize all of those, you know, inner awareness, really. Absolutely. And, you know, we were thinking about the move towards contextual admissions as well, and how actually what you've been through will be really useful in terms of your awareness of services, but also, you know, your ability to reflect and to draw on what you've been through. And whilst they say that you don't have to be hit by a bus to know that it hurts it sure does help you know in terms of your empathy for knowing what things feel like I wouldn't recommend everyone getting hit by a bus that is a figure of speech um okay so um yeah
而在以前，我是绝对做不到这些的。我以前会非常固执地按照自己的方式去做，非得做到100%不可。但是，你不可能随时随地都付出100%的自己。你需要能够休息。所以我觉得花点时间休息对我太有帮助了，它让我能够认识到所有这些内在觉察，真的。完全同意。而且，你知道，我们也在思考向情境化招生转变的趋势，以及你所经历的一切实际上将如何在对服务的认知方面对你非常有用，同时也包括你反思和借鉴自己经历的能力。虽然人们常说，你不需要被公交车撞才知道疼，但对于培养对事物感受的同理心而言，这确实很有帮助——我可不建议每个人都被公交车撞，那只是一种修辞手法。好的，所以……对
thank you so much for sharing your story with you and I know it's one that many will resonate with and that will be really useful for people in future um yeah no it's been a pleasure to to be on the podcast and I think when I reached out to you initially um I did not expect to you know be offered to be on the podcast and like I say at the start although there was a bit of apprehension to start with I just think it's you know it's nice to hear from somebody who's kind of been through different things and I know that I appreciate it when guests come on on the podcast it just offers you a new perspective and yeah I really appreciate being here and I hope that I have been of some value to others. You absolutely have and I knew that the questions you were asking were important considerations for so many aspiring psychologists so that's why yeah i'm really glad that you're
非常感谢你分享你的故事，我知道这个故事会引起很多人的共鸣，对未来的人们也会非常有用。是的，很高兴能来到这个播客。我想当我最初联系你的时候，我完全没想到自己会被邀请上播客。就像我一开始说的，虽然起初有点忐忑，但我只是觉得，能听到一个经历过各种不同事情的人分享，这种感觉真好。我知道当嘉宾来到播客时我非常感激，它只是为你提供了一个新的视角。是的，我非常感谢能来到这里，也希望我的经历能对他人产生一些价值。你绝对做到了。我知道你提出的问题对于许多有志成为心理学家的人来说都是重要的考量，所以这就是为什么我真的很高兴你能
able to be brave and wishing you all the best with the rest of your training but you know this is an opportunity you get an extra cohort to to have connections with and to draw on for support it's not always a negative you know there's you know benefits to all situations as well and whilst we don't need to shine up the dull side of a penny this is a nice opportunity that you're going in with the full awareness and insight into what this is going to be like and you're still choosing to do it but you get a whole new set of people to do it with and then your current cohort will be really interested in still supporting you and checking in with you so it's like it's a really nice situation hopefully too yeah absolutely I think
能够表现得勇敢，并祝你接下来的培训一切顺利。不过，你知道，这也是一个机会，让你能与额外的一届学员建立联系并获得支持，这并不完全是一件坏事。你知道的，所有情况都有其积极的一面。虽然我们不需要把暗淡的一面粉饰得太美好，但这确实是一个很好的机会，让你能带着对现状的充分认知和洞察去开启这段旅程，而且你依然选择这样做，同时你还有了一群全新的人和你一起经历。你现有的同届生也会非常乐意继续支持你、关心你，所以希望这也是一个非常不错的局面。是的，完全同意。我认为
it's I know I'm a bit of a believer in everything happens for a reason and this was what was meant to happen and I'm just you know taking taking it on board and just seeing what happens so I'm really excited for to start my training again in March and then you know over time we'll see what happens and when the time is ready I think I'll know when I should then start applying for the doctorate but for now I'm just going to focus on getting back on training and then getting qualified and we'll see what see what happens from there brilliant thank you so much for your time wishing you a lovely festive break um and yeah thank you for your time in recording this really important podcast episode Meg thank you thank you for having me and I hope that you have a lovely holiday period Thank you. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective
我知道自己有点相信“一切发生皆有原因”，这就是命中注定的安排。我只是在吸收这些经验，看看接下来会发生什么。所以我非常高兴能在3月份重新开始培训，随着时间的推移，我们会看到情况如何发展。当时机成熟时，我想我会知道自己何时应该开始申请博士学位。但现在，我只想专注于重新回到培训中并获得资格认证，然后看看从那里会发展成什么样。太棒了，非常感谢你的时间，祝你过一个愉快的节日假期。也谢谢你花时间录制这个非常重要的播客节目，梅格。谢谢你，谢谢你邀请我，也希望你度过一个愉快的假期。谢谢。有志心理学家集体
The Aspiring Psychologist Collective Hello, my name is Avalon and I'm an undergraduate psychology student. I really enjoyed reading The Aspiring Psychologist Collective and I really honestly just couldn't put it down. I found it really helpful because as I'm in my final year I'm starting to think about what I'd like to do after uni and up until this point I've been very set on the idea of pursuing an AP role and the Aspiring Psychologist Collective helped me to see that there
有志心理学家集体，大家好，我叫阿瓦隆，是一名心理学专业的本科生。我真的很喜欢阅读《有志心理学家集体》，说实话，我真的爱不释手。我发现这本书对我非常有帮助，因为我正处于大四，开始思考大学毕业后我想做什么。在此之前，我一直非常坚定期望从事助理心理学家（AP）的岗位，而《有志心理学家集体》帮助我看到
are so many more options out there that may appeal to me and I'm looking forward to exploring some of these and broadening out my options. And I also really appreciated that people were open about their lived experience and how they navigated this over their psychology journey. I had lived experience of an eating disorder, so it was really inspiring to hear about how people have brought that into their reflections and how it shaped the clinicians that they are today. Reflective accounts of mental health professionals On their way to getting qualified The Aspiring Psychologist Collective Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side
其实还有更多吸引我的选择，我很期待去探索其中的一些选择并拓宽我的视野。我也非常感激大家能够坦诚地分享他们的人生经历，以及他们在心理学旅程中是如何应对这些经历的。我曾有过进食障碍的亲身经历，所以听到大家如何将这些经历融入反思中，以及它们如何塑造了今天的临床医生，这让我备受启发。心理健康专业人士的反思记录，在通往获得专业资格的路上，《有志心理学家集体》那么就让这本书成为你的指南，让这个播客陪伴在你的左右
You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Marianne Trent my name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner I read the clinical psychologist collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me with confidence that, no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself.
你将迈向获得资格的道路。这就是《有志心理学家集体》播客，我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，我叫亚娜，是一名心理健康见习从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书，发现其中所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历都非常有趣。达到这个目标竟然有这么多不同的途径，这让我感到十分惊叹，而且成为临床心理学家并没有唯一完美的标准。这让我充满了信心，让我觉得“我并没有做错”，同时也减轻了我的压力。
So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书来让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦你翻开这本书，就再也放不下了。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。